[Music]
Eddie McCarthy has a new column out
today and it's entitled quote Democrats
complaints about the FBI investigation
are absurd he joins us now along with
the author of the number one New York
Times bestseller the Russian hoax Fox
News legal analyst Greg Jarrett the
chief counsel for the judicial crisis
Network Kari
Severino you know to me Andy from the
beginning it was about okay these are
the allegations now you asked the people
they said in every case that there were
people that could corroborate this and
every case that didn't happen unless
people change their mind remember under
penalty of a felony they're gonna admit
they committed a felony and change their
story I didn't think so
yeah well Sean this has always been
about delay from the very beginning
that's all it's been about it's not
surprising that they were not able to
corroborate these allegations I think
these allegations in a normal process
you would never have heard of them
because there's a way that the Senate
has to vet these kinds of claims where
people say they want to remain
confidential and they can go into this
sort of thing that's not what this was
ever about they were raising claims at
the last minute in order to force delay
they've pushed for an FBI investigation
to force delay every day that the FBI
investigation goes on they raise new
questions about the depth of it and what
it's actually about and the whole point
transparently has always been to push
this beyond the midterms in the hope
that they win the Senate and can beat
them on the numbers that's all this has
ever been about Kerry but mitch
mcconnell is as we speak breaking here
on fox is on the senate floor if he
files cloture that would tee up the four
day process to have a confirmation vote
on saturday that's if he files cloture
why would Mitch McConnell at 9:52
Eastern Time DC time beyond the Senate
floor if he's not filing cloture here
well III think that's a definite
possibility that he's ready to do that
now we've got the FBI report that's what
everyone said we were waiting for and so
it at this point if he does that there's
still at this intervening day so we have
all of tomorrow to kind of think about
it and then they
have the cloture vote and have this time
to debate so there's still lots of time
they have a schedule Saturday the
earliest Saturday with the earliest
there's lots of opportunity for the
Senators themselves to look at this
report you know what it was talk to
Murkowski or Collins well I think I know
the leader McConnell is definitely
talking to them and they get they had
said just along the lines that Senator
Coons said this is let's have a let's
have a constrained give us a week let
you got it now we've now we've had the
opportunity and I think if it's gonna
make them very comfortable great but we
didn't get anything new out of it so
there's repercussions great to do
process well it it's sad but there is no
due process there's no fundamental
fairness there is no presumption of
innocence among the media and Democrats
and I find it amazing
now that the very individual Dianne
Feinstein who concealed the information
initially now is attempting to conceal
the FBI report that she demanded this
has been careening wildly out of control
and the only way to slam the brakes on
this imminent train wreck is to be open
and honest and transparent and yet
that's not what Dianne Feinstein never
why maybe because she wants to
misrepresent the contents of that report
which apparently offer absolutely no
corroboration and only refutation of the
accusations that have been handy does
does Cavanaugh get confirmed or the
smears work no I think he gets confirmed
Shawn I saw you speak to speaker
Gingrich earlier tonight I think I think
he's right on I think he has a right
he'll get confirm okay I agree
especially people like Manchin Heitkamp
it's a thirty point difference in those
states I think they they're gonna really
want to have to vote we won't do it
unless the Republicans have the vote so
that's my prediction we'll give you the
last prediction Frank Jarrett I think he
gets confirmed and he may actually get a
couple of Democrats on board once they
read the contents of this FBI report
that apparently those of us who suffered
through this spectacle don't get to see
by the way this just breaking McConnell
just filed
as I thought he might